[Music]
this morning we're launching a new
series called eye
on innovation it will feature stories
about the
increasing role science and technology
play in our lives
cutting edge technology is now shining a
light on a mysterious sea creature
called
a larvation write that name down class
you'll be quizzed on it later okay
the little critter appears to be a vital
and powerful ally
in the fight against climate change
jonathan vigliotti spoke with scientists
at the monterey bay aquarium research
institute who introduced us to an animal
we
might not be able to live without
if you drained monterey bay in central
california you would see a chasm
the size of the grand canyon
it's here that scientists just
discovered a key
to how the oceans keep carbon out of our
atmosphere
these animals that are less than 10
centimeters in size are planting playing
outsized
roles in in how things are moving around
and functioning in our ocean
there's the laser housing here
kakani katija is the engineer who built
and deployed
this unique camera and laser scanning
system it was just used to look
inside a creature that has puzzled and
amazed scientists
for decades
[Music]
her team attached that system to a
remote underwater vehicle
that dove almost a mile deep in the bay
to find their elusive subject
what are larvaceans what's really
amazing about these animals is their
ability to
create really complex structures
completely out of mucus that they
secrete
the camera gave them these images of the
tiny creature
at the center of a sometimes three foot
diameter web
of intricately constructed mucus
three feet of snot exactly so you know
some people say snot palace so it's not
pellets
i feel like a palace is a better term
than just a house just because of
the complexity right do you want me to
turn more east bridge
but it was only when the crew deployed
their new laser scanning device that
they were able to explore
the interiors of those palaces that's
when they discovered the creature's
vital role in the ecosystem those mucous
structures serve to
filter particles and food from the water
around them you know those particles are
essentially made up of carbon
they actually stay kind of confined or
trapped within those mucous structures
and these animals will actually abandon
these structures
swim away and build new ones that's the
animal's mouth right there
as the larvaceans swim away the
particle-laden webs
sink to the ocean floor keeping that
carbon trapped
or in the marine food cycle and out of
earth's atmosphere
we have estimates that they filter
anywhere from 40 to
up to 80 liters per hour 80 liters of
water an hour
per individual here in monterey bay
that's approximately 500
olympic site swimming pools being
filtered per hour
since carbon in our atmosphere traps
heat and warms the planet
scientists say anything that helps keep
it sequestered in the ocean
is a huge ally in our battle against
climate change
i spent a lot of time looking to nature
for
designs or developments that could be
inspirational
for new engineering technologies and so
this is where i'm hoping the research
will go
how possible is it for man and woman to
mimic
what the larvation does it's a great
question i wish i knew the answer
it seems to me that if we could somehow
tap into what the larvacean knows
and does we could eliminate carbon
permanently
perhaps it's hard to say at this point
what's easier to say is that since
larvaceans have been found in every
ocean basin
on earth these tiny palace builders of
the sea
play a huge role in keeping life
sustainable for us
back on land they're amazing engineers
they are amazing engineers for cbs this
morning
jonathan vigliotti monterey bay
california
wow is that fascinating yeah it loses a
creepiness when you see what they're
doing
wow the work they're doing it's a little
creepy but a mucus palace yeah you lost
me with the snot palace and the mucous
ballast but
i got past that and you see what they're
doing i love this new series of the bar
is now pretty high for good stories
it was an amazing piece the images too
were stunning and katana katija one of
the best names ever
like that too nice you liked everything
but the mucus